good morning believe nation today's
messages that money should be spent but
never squandered over to you Lee cashing
awake Express the TV go you got you
donate a Latina Association there's a
Victoria Coco and you'll know you're
mine good nominee tonight I go knocked
away by Koga cheer look kohada
movie gonna chase you look a lot nicer
go 200 lumen Samoa Oh mornin it's a mall
order the CLA Chopra move aside from
your young doe younger Honka Latino mo
the reason is of my little koi carp also
topped alderman shebang most of the
monkey Eloy modern omni apartment beggar
come on you [ __ ] ang ang a demon
Molly oh man yo mam lado de Santi local
oh the local honky Lamar Gaius icy moons
over that was either ma over like oh
yeah pop mango bay good we won't talk
about creative Honda seungji teen voice
I don boylar look like I think a lot of
entrepreneurs squander money for those
of you who've been a loyal part of my
channel you know that I'm not a fan of
spending money until I'm making money
and a lot of entrepreneurs you do the
exact opposite you start spending tons
of money before you're making anything
and I'm all about putting your energy
your hustle your time your drive into
something but don't spend anything until
you are making money so some of you who
want to start a YouTube channel you go
and you buy a camera on a tripod and
light in a backdrop and a microphone and
a tripod and all the things that you
need to do to start a YouTube channel
and then you only make one video you
look at it you hate it and decide ah
this YouTube thing isn't for me
some of you will want to start a t-shirt
company so you go out and you spend a
ton of money buying t-shirts and because
you need to order 5000 to get the
quantity discounts you buy 5000 and you
end up filling up your garage or your
basement your apartment your condo or
your parents house and you're stuck with
4995 t-shirts that you just can't sell
so as of today I want you to stop
squandering money prove to yourself
first that you can make money doing this
before you start spending it on
something so my question of the day
today I want to get a little deeper
today I want to look at a limiting
belief of yours I want you to write in
the comments below what you feel like
you can't get started on because you
haven't invested in this
I can't launch my business because I
don't have enough money to do this what
is this and then I want believe nation
to reply to each other I want you to
jump in there help each other out to
think about what's a lower cost free way
to get started to help that person solve
that problem leave it in the comments
below thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot event spresso it's
windy and I don't want the money to fly
away spray so give me go
on